[electronic music]
Sandeep: Hi.
My name is Sandeep,
a developer advocate
on the Google Cloud platform.
Welcome to the Google
Data Center
at the Dalles, Oregon.
Take a look around.
Before we go inside,
we need to make sure
that we have the appropriate
security clearance.
Most Google employees can't
even get in here.
So let's go on a special
behind-the-scenes tour.
[keypad beeps, door opens]
I'm here with Noah
from the Site Reliability
Engineering Team.
Noah, can you tell us
a little bit more
about the SRE role at Google?
Noah: Yeah, SREs write and
maintain the software systems
designed to keep
our services running.
Sandeep: So what happens if
one of these systems goes down?
Noah: We've designed our systems
from the ground up
to be able to handle
any unexpected failures
that might occur.
We have highly redundant
power, networking,
and serving domains so that
even if we do lose
an entire cluster, we're able
to re-direct those workloads
and live migrate data in
order to minimize any impact.
In addition, we have a team
of SREs on call 24/7
that can tackle any problems
that might arise.
Sandeep: Thanks, Noah.
Now we've learned more
about the systems
that manage our fleet
at Google,
let's take a deeper look
at the data center
infrastructure itself.
Before we can
continue further,
we need to go through
the biometric iris scan
and circle lock.
These only allow one person
in at a time
and require
dual authentication
to continue further.
I'll see you
on the other side.
[control beeps]
computer voice: Please
situate your eyes
to begin the procedure.
Please come a little closer
to the camera.
[beep]
Sandeep: Welcome to
the data center floor.
As you can tell, we have
a lot of servers,
and this is a single cluster
in a single floor
in a single building.
Managing all of these servers
on a global scale
is quite a challenge.
To utilize our fleet,
we use tools
such as Borg, Colossus,
and Spanner.
You may be familiar
with similar tools,
such as Kubernetes,
Google Cloud storage,
and BigQuery.
These tools allow
Google engineers
and Cloud customers
to more easily manage
infrastructure,
allowing everyone to build
innovative and scalable
applications.
Here at Google, a lot of our
infrastructure is custom-made.
This gives us the flexibility
and performance
we need to run
all of our services at scale.
Oh, hey, it's Virginia,
one of our network engineers.
Virginia: Hey, Sandeep.
Sandeep: Virginia,
what are you working on today?
Virginia: Today I'm working
with Hardware Ops
to expand
this data center network
to deploy additional machines
in this building.
Our fleet is constantly growing
to support new capacity
for Google products
and our Cloud customers.
Sandeep: That sounds like
a lot of work,
to be constantly adding capacity
around the globe.
Virginia: Well, we designed
our network
so that this kind of capacity
growth isn't very hard.
Jupiter, our current data center
and network technology,
is a hierarchical design
using software-defined
networking principles.
So just like with our servers,
we abstracted away the specific
details of our network
and can manage them like they're
software programs and data.
Sandeep: Abstracting seems to be
a common theme here at Google.
I've also noticed
there's a lot of fiber
running in our data centers.
Virginia: That's right.
A single building can
support 75,000 machines,
and carry over one petabit
per second of bandwidth,
which is actually more than
on the entire Internet.
Sandeep: Wow.
Virginia: This allows us
to reliably access storage
and compute resources
with low latency
and high throughput.
Sandeep: So how is
this data center connected to
all our other data centers
around the globe?
Virginia: Google runs B4,
our own private, highly
efficient backbone network,
which is actually growing faster
than our Internet-facing
network.
It connects all
our data centers together
and allows services to
efficiently access resources
in any location.
Sandeep: Nice.
I finally know what all this
Google fiber is really used for.
Thanks, Virginia.
Virginia: No problem.
Sandeep: So now you've seen
all the compute and networking
horsepower
required to run your workloads
in the Cloud,
let's take a look
at where your data is
safely and securely stored.
Let's go.
Whether you're querying
terabytes of data on BigQuery
or storing petabytes
in Google Cloud Storage,
all of your data needs to
be stored on a physical device.
Our data center infrastructure
allows us
to access our storage
quickly and securely.
At our scale, we need to handle
hard drive and SSD failure
on a daily basis.
While your data
is replicated and safe,
we need to destroy or recycle
used hard drives
so no one can access your data.
From the time a disc
is removed from the server
to the time it's decommissioned,
we maintain a very strict chain
of custody.
The discs are completely wiped
and then destroyed
in a huge shredder.
Let's go shred some hard drives.
[beeping]
We've looked at
a lot of the hardware
that runs in our data centers,
but it doesn't end there.
We need to cool and power
our infrastructure
in an environmentally
sustainable and reliable way.
Let's take a look
at how we cool our servers.
Welcome to the mechanical
equipment room.
Looks pretty cool,
doesn't it?
Oh, hey, it's Brian,
one of
our data center
facilities technicians!
Brian: Hey, Sandeep.
Sandeep: Hey, Brian.
Brian, can you tell us a little
bit more about this room?
Brian: Sure.
This is a cooling plant
for one of the data centers
that we have on site.
So a lot of heat is generated
on the server floor,
and it all has to be removed,
and that starts right here
in the cooling plant.
So it's basically two loops.
We have the condenser
water loop
and we have
the process water loop.
The process water loop are these
blue and red pipes over here.
So they take the heat
off the server floor
and they transfer it to
these heat exchangers here.
The condenser water loop are
these green and yellow
pipes here.
They take the cold water
from the basin underneath us,
they transfer it to
these heat exchangers here,
and they send it up to the
cooling towers up on the roof.
Sandeep: I notice our pipes
are Google colors.
It's pretty cool.
So how efficient is
our data center?
Brian: Well, Google has
some of
the most efficient data centers
in the world.
In fact, when we started
reporting our power usage effectiveness
or P.U.E., in 2008,
most data centers
were around 100% overhead.
At that point in time,
Google was 20% overhead,
but since then,
we've reduced it to just 12%,
and that even includes
our cafeterias.
Sandeep: Whoa!
That is so low!
Also what's this big
green machine for?
Brian: Oh, well,
this is a chiller.
We very rarely use them,
but it helps keep the process
water temperature
in the desired temperature range
when it gets really hot outside,
basically helping
the cooling tower do its job,
and some of
our newer data centers,
they have no chillers at all.
Sandeep: I love how our new data
centers are even more efficient.
By the way, can we go up and
take a look at a cooling tower?
Brian: Sure.
Let's go.
Sandeep: Wow,
what a view up here!
Brian: So, Sandeep,
this is a cooling tower.
It uses evaporation
to rapidly cool the water
from the condenser loop and
sends it back down to the basin.
You could say we're making
actual clouds with the Cloud.
Sandeep: Clouds making actual
clouds--welcome to Google!
So, Brian, how do
we power the Cloud?
Brian: Well, that all starts at
Google's power substation.
Let's go take a look.
So this is the Google-owned
power substation.
This is where the high voltage
power enters the site.
It's reduced and then sent
to multiple power
distribution centers
such as this one right here.
Sandeep: What happens if
a power distribution center
loses power?
Brian: If it loses power,
we have
multiple generator
and utility backup sources
available to maintain power
to those servers.
Sandeep: And where does
all the power come from?
Brian: It actually comes from
multiple hydroelectric
power plants
that are nearby.
Sandeep: I love how Google uses
reliable green energy
whenever possible.
Brian: We are
100% carbon neutral actually.
Sandeep: That's pretty cool
You know, it seems like
Google builds reliability
from the ground up,
from the power and cooling
all the way to the software
systems that manage our fleet.
Thanks for showing me around,
Brian.
Brian: No problem.
Have a great day.
Sandeep: Thank you
for joining me on
this special
behind-the-scenes tour.
Please check out
cloud.google.com
to learn how you can build
what's next.